Good morning, good evening, good afternoon.
I'm a tired wee bobby this morning alright so you're gonna have to forgive me.
I woke up four minutes ago and I made a tea just in time. Very nice.
We are your friends. Can you tell I just woke up? Is it obvious or is it like one of those things
where uh you can get away with it? I'm going to pin my marshmallow because you're more than welcome
to ask me any questions because I couldn't think of like a uh here nor there type of stream to do
and I was like look if I put up a game it's already game over but if I claim I'm doing a zatsu I know
I will go offline at the right time because uh we're going to write oh sorry about the cursed
ASMR please let me remove that right here right here oh it just has message retracted now no that's
not why I was one at all feel free to ask any question for me for me and then and then we do
pen replace pinned message you do send a little sleepy oh no the ipi i'm i'm very ipi right now but
if I can get away with that we're gonna get away with it okay um okay and you can actually hear
my background music for once I like never play the dang thing but it's so good but good morning
good evening good afternoon uh I have a new short out and I have a new ASMR collab out I'm so glad
because now I have two collabs out and I have two like subscriber thank yous which means I can
put my playlist together and I'm gonna call it my 100 um 100 vtuber ASMR collabs and then 100
thank you subscribers the strong bounty um but yeah we were in a freaking magazine oh my gosh
I'm gonna talk about it okay are you ready are you ready so if you didn't know there's this
magazine that covers vtuber news and it's called acapella media um they actually recently just
combined with a vtuber news drop um which is another website um but I said you know what effort
I believe it was me I reached out to them and I said look I said look look acapella media let me
shake I want to shake your hand okay so I shook acapella media's hand I was like look here's the
situation all right uh we're debuting on June 1st now we'd love the opportunity to be interviewed
okay the magazine name is acapella media I don't have my accent scripture in that but it's acapella
media it says acapella at the top in the sweet image um and I was like look you can even ask
questions that are off tables for other agencies okay um and like we're happy to even come up with
the questions to make it as easy and simple as possible now I say this all the time if you want
something to happen make it as easy and simple as possible for the other party involved so I was
like I can even come up with the questions if you want which I didn't thankfully I didn't have to do
okay I didn't have to do they they did give us questions um so this is what was kind of cute
this is one of the things I couldn't talk about that was cooking in the background there's still
another thing in the background that I can't talk about yeah but there's a few more things okay
so we got sent these questions uh I think a week after debut and the the girls you know we're
racking their brain so we're gonna go I'm gonna read out their answers so up first I am going to
I hold holly molly I am so big hold on I don't know what to do well oh no Zura you're getting
covered by chat oh my chat I'm sorry you're gonna have to get covered a wee bit I can't even read
I'm flying hold on oh no I can't read it can you guys even read that
no wait make me so make me shit smaller
I don't know are you covering those I'm a wee bit but like I can't right hold on right so
viewer interview as Zura delay okay I'm going to do it in the Zura voice the fertility goddess
okay we're never just gonna do this okay this is terrible this is so scoff look I've just woken up
be nice to me go go get your 4k screen got as Zura looks gorgeous you like her uh promotional
artwork like she ain't got toes painted yet that's how a quick that was made before production was
finalized uh huh don't don't tell anyone okay I ordered the promotional artwork before the designs
are final finalized because promotional artwork takes a lot of time okay right this is a Zura's
response to the questions don't worry I'll read it all out so if you're blind as a bat or you need
your glycs on is any of you worried I've got you covered uh-huh Vila is the first agency of its kind
which means we're horn dogs on me maybe pin the thread oh maybe well oh yeah okay pin the thread
you know what you actually know what can what we fling you're actually so right right now
so acapella media I'm gonna kiss them on the lips and I'm gonna do it a couple of times and guess what
this does uh yeah let me just get the fucking thing right hold on hold steady steady right acapella
media acapella media surely that's how you spell it surely copy them I'm probably absolutely butchered
the dang thing acapella media and then this is where we are okay pin and then I'll swap it to the the
the the Q&A on what what a melon on marshmallow I've just woken up I'm so sorry I just fucking
what a melons myself there for no reason at all oh my god I she tired I had a nightmare and it was
awful I woke up covered in sweat that was quite the sleeping session let's not happen let's not do
that again okay body do I make myself clear okay vealor is the first agency of its kind horn dogs on me
what did you why did you choose vealor instead of remaining independent Azura and Azura said
I saw a great opportunity and vealor entrusted in our vision the support a company can give its
talent is a great starting point oh thank you Azura really you're far too kind but how important
was the amount of freedom with content creation being open to discussing pls etc for you I don't
really want to discuss my pl but I'm happy that I get the freedom to talk about some aspects of
life even when wanting to create new memories and the future for myself oh sure that's so kind of you
I'm glad that you enjoyed that uh we're an agency that doesn't acknowledge your fucking brand new
out the out the out the package okay thank you Azura I appreciate that and what platform did you
want to make content on prior to being a part of vealor Azura since I originally streamed on Twitch
I wanted to make the move to youtube and continue making content there including shorts and I actually
speaking of shorts Azura sorry to interrupt you I've just ordered four shorts of you right now
okay I'm just waiting on an asset and there's four shorts coming they're quite humorous okay okay
strong thank you yes actually she calls me stroney as in minna stroney like she didn't go stroney
she was stroney and it's fucking amazing love you Azura oh I'll keep calling you stroney then since
you love yeah yeah thanks Azura okay sorry to interrupt you back to the question uh as content
there doesn't entirely get removed after a few days like twitch box okay thank you Azura okay
but what inspired you to create content or content in general for that matter Azura
I've always had a feel for voice acting and always wanted to take part in some kind of way
the many voices that approached me were compliment towards my voice and how I should pursue it
which piqued my curiosity in the air however the many voices claimed my voice is extremely
erotic oh so when the opportunity appeared it felt like it was meant to be oh wow I agree with
that I am sure people did compliment you I have no doubts about that Azura I absolutely no doubts
at all um is there any content you're particularly interested in making well that would be the
awesome raw place oh Azura all right I also look forward to being in other opportunity oh is that a hint to the video game Azura
Azura is that a hint to the video game I don't know by the way before anyone's like oh new viewer
here I thought stroney was a mix of strong and funny oh um for anyone who's like uh did you
look over the girls answers and stuff uh I think I fixed one sentence and it was in mercies
that's it I've not changed any all these answers are what they actually said I fixed one sentence
in mercies which I actually didn't tell her about sorry mercy yeah fuck you stroney that's not what
you sound like anyway well double fuck you then right whoa whoa whoa sit down sit down whoa
I'm fighting myself here okay stop stop okay uh do you have any uh other content creators advice on
how to navigate uh creating uh alternative content on the internet especially when it comes
safely navigating it because I miss the word safely there if it's a view tubing related and you wish
to keep your identity private try not to share too much information that could put you at risk for
but it's perfectly okay to be honest and do things that make what
don't oh don't force your side I fucking can't read in my own interview yeah is there are you okay
do you need glasses you know you're the fucking I'm putting my glasses on okay hold on right glasses
are on right everything's enlarged I can actually see no Azura just I'm fucking made that up hold on
me fucking neglects Azura I'll let her it this is the lore oh it steady on right uh don't force
yourself to do things that make you uncomfortable and the rather open up slowly okay I'll open you
up slowly Azura thank you uh right what was the next question uh what do you hope to bring or
change in the view tubing landscape Azura I don't think I can change much of anything but I would
hope that people can see more person of color talent in the image oh I like that thank you thank
you for fucking ego stroking the other I didn't even have to ask for that oh this cup of tea
you know what reflens sometimes I make a mead cup of tea all I'm saying is that when we do
the meet up I'm making everyone a cup of tea I'm gonna be I'm gonna have a little trolley and I'll
be like coffee or tea and there's only one real answer honey tea I know she's like literally all
the girls were stroking the bealer I'm like god damn I didn't even have to prompt them
oh thank you very much AC did you enjoy your your gorilla guild wars two stream
I wonder why she wanted round two of that stream hmm yeah I wonder that the only thing I know about
AC's previous guild war stream is she got a train ran on her uh hmm I wonder why she wanted to play
it again with the snowberries truly a mystery hmm yes yes that's right dad as we did it again I knew
you fucking did it I knew it I knew it haunted deep thank you for becoming a member I knew you
did it again there is no way you guys weren't gonna do it again you know what she's gonna do that innocent
little feral polar bear is gonna go offline and do you know exactly what I know exactly what she's
doing right now I'm sorry but she fucking enjoys that too much someone clipped her and I saw it
and she's like burst out laugh and when you'll start jumping on her and I was like yeah die
okay innocent honestly
look she's my baby girl okay she my she my doll face she my doll face
mm-hmm okay we're currently reading Azur's interview from a acapella media look at them
I just revealed a bit of secret lore about um the uh design uh the promotional artwork this was
ordered before the designs were finalized because look Azur doesn't have her nails painted and one
of the biggest giveaways is her headband if it has floating jewellery that's actually uh that's
actually a massive giveaway on if uh the artwork was completed or not at that point um they forgot
about the jewellery on their toes oh yeah actually yeah that was another big thing so you can tell
what stage of panic in production we were at depending on what the thing was but now everything's
made correctly um oh oh my god the tea is steaming up my glasses I forget glasses steam up
okay I've had my tea right back to the questions uh Azur can I keep question yet of course
Stroney okay thank you Azur um right what's one thing you want people to remember about you
individually or as a generation I may not be the first but I started with almost nothing
I did the best I could and achieved very little I just want to show others that it's very possible
and you shouldn't give up I still have a long way to go yes um I I think me and Azura are completely
on the exact same page when I say this um I see a lot of potential in Azura which is why she's Azura
um you know I I see myself and the girls to different degrees and Azura was definitely
and I don't think this is an insult in any way I think she completely 100% gets what why I say this
I think Azura is the the version of me that I see that I needed a helping hand or a gating hand
and once you know things settle down and everything I'm going to try and get her moved out with her
donathon that's coming up next month which is actually really exciting it comes up in August
I'm going to try and get her moved out and then things can kind of I think it's upwards and onwards
for Azura after that the underdog yes I I I'm a sucker for my underdog I always root for them
and I think Azura has insane potential she just needs a few things to occur
and then I I think she's got it she's absolutely she's got nothing to worry about
um but we just need to first get her moved out and then I can just nuke her brain on all the
secrets and behind the scenes stuff okay my little pad of one yes uh right um what do you want to
represent in the v-tube sphere Azura I'm not I just I know I'm just another voice but I want to do
so much more with that voice I always thought my voice was very no it's not I Azura I picked you
because you said I need more gold in your goddamn voice I was about to cross off your damn stream
you're a league player you but maybe I can find something that can truly represent in the beach
on the sphere yes um Azura humble max and literally I everyone knows why I picked them
I told them I said it on debut and I told them like one on one like hey this is why you got picked
or type thing um now you have to remember this is the first time Azura has ever been in any kind
of spotlight kind of had this attention so please don't be afraid if the girls may have said something
that wasn't the kindest to themselves they're not all confident you know they can't all be
just absolutely arrogant like myself um so if you see if you see a reply and you're like oh that's
a wee shame just remember these some of these girls have never achieved anything close to what
they've achieved in the very first month of the very first month at Vilaura they have not achieved
that and they're at their time as a content creator so very yes we will grow and blossom their
confidence just as the beautiful nasturtiums blossom you know stroney you're just being truthful
to yourself as an arrogant okay one more question for Azura and we have finalized Azura's interview
mm-hmm uh Azura is there any event in VTubing history that is incredibly significant to you
there isn't one that particularly stood out to me but I suppose seeing the rise of Vilaura
already coming out with the person of color talent right off the bat was incredibly nice
as well as management being open to more person of color designs behind the scenes
and developments was very reassuring it wasn't a publicity stunt now I have a oh boy do I have
some information about gen 2 to leak to you motherfuckers uh yeah you're not ready for what
occurred yesterday with the development team oh boy right that is uh beautiful Azura Dooley
please do uh find her youtube channel in the link in the description below you can subscribe
check out her shorts I will be getting her new short she's the next batch of shorts and then it
goes to Sheebie and then we're rotating all over again because a few of the shorts editors uh have
exams etc so I'm having to rotate gracefully between each girl to try and give them a fair
amount of shorts um but we're not quite there yet but thank you so much for that interview
Azura that was fantastic you may go and rest for your stream today which is probably League of
Legends because you're fucking addicted uh okay uh oh thank you Strony Minestrone soup oh thank you
no Azura you're so thank you for being my mummy quite literally my mummy well thank you for being
my mummy hey hey Azura stop it you got me blushing i'm reading stuff right out you go out you go right
thank you thank you right who's next oh icy snow paws speaking of the snowberries who do we have
up next she's not streaming the day oh yeah piss right that's not good icy snow paws our the feral
polar bear of the allure uh again the do you want to know how you can tell this art wasn't
finalized notice how icy doesn't have any fluff coming off of her hips design there's no fluff
coming off of her little hips uh this was made again before the designs were like fully fleshed
out and finalized and it was utter chaos trying to get this dang right okay says you strong
but how do you how do you okay uh icy and you come and you come oh thank you for having me on
stream i just finished a fucking hell icy you're really rushing the day i don't know what happened
to my accent what the fuck okay well anyway and never mind that right let's ask you some questions
sorry okay um okay dada is thank you for running a trade i see no interview today
okay interview vealor is the first agency of its kind why did you my little icicle choose it
instead of remaining independent um i already had a previously good experience with them
and from that day why does it sound like a zero i always for fuck hold on let me pull up ac right
now hold on let me pull up ac stream so i can fucking mimic tear her right now hold on pause
pause the interview you'd be quiet just for a week second ac okay my darling what the fuck
yeah no it's fine it's fine it's fine right debut highlights hello everybody hi it's so good to see
you hello i already have a pretty a previously good experience with the investor and from that day i
always had a good impression of her so when i heard of the plans she was making i wanted to take
part of it so much because i knew i'd feel safer under her wing and the concept of vealor i'm trying
just to appeal the last to me being an indie was also very lonely to be in a group of girls that
are degenerates like me i'm not right though like working all together to reach her dream sounded like
the perfect place for me oh that's so lovely ac i'm so glad that you feel comfortable around
us all being degenerates okay for the next question my little icicle how important was the
amount of freedom that content creation being open with your pl etc was for you it was pretty
important it was it make me nervous and overwhelmed if i had to rethink everything i say in fear of
getting in trouble for it okay i just like to be comfy and to talk about whatever without worrying
about that stuff oh i'm yeah no it honestly it's fine i'm not gonna pretend that you've never streamed
before ever in your life okay i'm losing it's almost like i'm losing my mind hearing all these
voices um okay uh what platforms did you want to make content on prior being on vealor my little
icicle pretty much all of them are the known ones like twitch and youtube and twitter and patreon
et cetera all right okay okay what inspired you to create content or just content in general
for that matter hold on i need to refresh oh my name is icicle i have always done things on the
creative side or have many ideas i wanted to bring to life seeing the things that people would create
or do puts a fire in me you know what else is in her today the fucking dad does
stop running a train oh my god thank you back to you ac that's far wait hold on what's your
voice again it's no pause that's far to want to try and create those things myself everything
expires me from music to art to poems to movies to animation god damn ac you pull from a love
inspiration um are we sure stroney is a cut official not apparent do you have any advice
for other content creators to navigate the field safety be careful with how much you share of your
identity it sometimes makes you feel off or uncomfortable oh if something makes you feel
off or comfortable don't engage with it and in general just don't do the 18 plus content
if you think you might regret it later uh she really said if you're born a slag be a slag
ac oh my god right okay uh you might regret later once it's on the internet it's there forever
i would only advise going into it if it's something you're very passionate about and should enjoy
want to do it long term oh my god ac you're hilarious oh my god right what do you hope to
bring or to change in the v-trip and landscape well we've all seen 3d concerts like the big ones
where people can watch in person it is my dream to achieve something similar but in a form of a
3d 3d dj party with all of the violor oh that's fucking adorable she actually did say this in her
application to us um i'd make for such a cool thing to experience with more interaction dancing
and lots of fun oh she's so cute she put this in her application i really made it stand out because
now if anyone's lurking that just happens to have applied you know there's a lot of reasons
obviously again it was like 64 candidates the one model so it wasn't easy but um
3d dj party madness no no no no no no no every strongy streamer's like i'll have a viola
reading it now um what was this one oh yeah um like some people didn't really have much goals
or aspirations etc they're just like i'm just happy to do my thing and i was like that's good
and all but it was good to have like a someone come in with like a really strong goal like this is
what i want to achieve like she's got something to work towards which is quite nice uh but i say
i'm not finished uh asking you the question so what do you want to represent in the v-tribe
sphere and just for those of us at home how does your voice go in? tarot polar bear from tarot polar bear
it's a bit tough for me to think of that because i don't think there's anything i really represent
besides myself oh you're so humble the closest thing i can think of is to represent is being
yourself the most authentic version of you is the ideal version the right people will see that
in you even if you take some years i had i'm losing it i had many nights where i cry oh
hey so what the fuck i had many nights where i cried or was worried that i'm not it's not going to
happen but it did and now i'm here and i'm the most fulfilled i've ever been yeah after that stream
don't give up yes i see you're very fulfilled right now thanks for that dad as i see you there
what's one thing you want people to remember about you individually or as a generation
i think what i'd like people to remember about us as a generation is that even if we are a
whore all of the girls have a lot of personality they are talented they're sweet they're incredible
people that deserve to achieve their dream and i also think that it'd be sweet and a bit funny
that the corpo with the horse is the one who ended up being the most wholesome and entertaining
what oh my god i see i can't believe you said that i lied
her pushers win honestly v sucky dub honestly okay last question for you i see and then you
can retire for the evening after your very uh exciting gaming session early okay last question
for you my my darling is there an event in vitra being that is incredibly significant to you
hmm i can't see oh wait that's that's my voice i can't say that there is i kind of just always
focused on the things i am doing and what i wanted to but i wouldn't say any of them because a huge
significant part for me what the fuck oh it's more like did i skip a sentence it's more like reading
the news and being updated about what's going on in the vitra being world oh icicle that's fantastic
i think i skipped a line there i wanted to achieve but there's a lot of big things that happen but
okay thank you so much icicle you may go rest i'm sure you're uh absolutely aching in a certain
location of your body but that's fine it's fine okay who's up next on the chopping block thank you
for that interview thank you bunny go good night uh yeah yeah that's virginia wherever as you see
thanks uh let me hold on let me get let me fill up and make so i can pretend i can do her voice
holy crap she's impossible for me she is genuinely impossible for me
what is this is this a wanted poster for me and she's not wanted oh i'm so sorry and then hold on
and it's so close to my cabin too it's so close to my cabin too what the heck what the heck i'm so
sorry emmy this is the best i got this is the best i got i'm sorry the masochistic little sis
i'm so sorry emmy this is this is all i got as for her artwork i think she was actually correct
design wise yeah she was actually correct design wise at this point emmy was the first to be
produced and nailed basically uh oh the hammer no yeah no she's got a hammer and all that and then
that's her bit colder on the other side yep uh looks good to me i think uh emmy's uh came out
was like right okay right hold on yeah we nailed emmy first okay well you know i guess i can use
this to problem oh gosh that's such a lame voice uh vealor is the first agency was came why did you
choose instead of remaining independent some of the jupy companies have a track record of being
unreliable wink wink if you know you know and i knew i'm so sorry i can't do your voice and i knew
this wasn't gonna happen here stop i need some like creams for fucking sonic heroes so uh obviously
my name is emmy bezu so my parents name me bezu some feature for companies have a track record of
being unreliable wink wink if you know you know and i knew that wasn't gonna happen here so sorry this
is awful so it was either i was joining this company or none at all it's fucking cream it's
actually cream from sonic heroes i'm so sorry emmy i can't do it i was i was doing okay independently
i was just lonely and struggled to keep up with my friends and now i'm forced to keep up with them
i can't hang i love the girls and she literally put xd oh my god i shouldn't hang out to save her
the cringe but it's fine i'll a little bit emmy eh i'll a little bit ac without the accent works
top priority i wouldn't top priority i wouldn't no what the fuck why can't i
emmy after the japanese word for emoto after the japanese word for emoto how important was
oh for goodness sake i'm sorry i think i'm gonna have to make emmy scottish i'm just gonna make
emmy like scottish i think how important was the amount of freedom emmy uh about content creation
about being open up to discussing pl's top priority i wouldn't be here if they didn't allow me to be
open about my pl it is not her voice at all um right like scottish also wait that's deep also
have a lot of rules sound stressful always worrying if you did something wrong i'm just doing
creams from sonic here i'm sorry emmy emmy rose team rose always worrying if you did something
wrong or said something against the rules uh yeah uh pretty much hi i'm new here i'm currently
mimicking my gen mates and i literally can't do anything you want timo is timo the one with the
accent i just accepted yeah literally emmy went to scotland on her break oh my god confirmed
eh what platform do you want to make content or what can't what platform did you want to make
content on prior revealer um i made content on twitch and tiktok and instagram and twitter
and youtube and patreon prior fucking hell you've got you're stacked out of the wazoo obviously most
of it was just reposting stuff from one platform to the other to reach a brighter audience okay thank
you emmy um but what inspired you to create that kind of content okay what is pl means previous life
so um other kind of personas you might have made content under etc like again when you join
veal or you get a whole new persona given to you eh what made you inspire inspire to make that kind
of content they listened to a lot of blue dot i mean did you actually put on an interview you did
well this is published okay i also consumed a lot of erotic literature so i had a lot of fun
creating my own scripts too okay that's actually the same i never thought i'd actually be creating it
because i naturally sound like the erm actually about t which is the least sexy thing imaginable
but that's where the voice acting comes into play i know i i didn't know you voice acted for
krema sonic heroes so i mean here we are um is there any content you're particularly interested
in making i want to make more art i just have to find the time and energy and some inspiration
you heard your pen pals you heard your big bros gi or some inspiration off you pop
scotch accent brought you here and this stream is all about not being scotch well i'm just reading
their interviews and then i'm like doing my default voice do you have any advice for other
content creators i want to safely navigate the 18 plus field just hide your identity and don't
become close personal friends with the people that consume your content it just gets too dangerous
okay so keep yourself safe please wow you really do sound like krema i know how tempting it is to
get close but you're playing with fire what do you hope to change or bring in the v-tubing
landscape i mean okay i don't really hope to bring or change anything right out here with the goal
to be a transistor to travel with thank god you're so humble that's too much pressure okay i felt
a lot to be honest i just want to make my audience smile laugh and and me you didn't even substitute
the word like put ink oh my god hey me i had no wait i'm like i'm like 90% sure i read over
their stuff i must have approved this what the fuck i read because i remember i changed one sentence
of mercies because she was a bit harsh on herself um i must have approved this oh my god i mean
shout out to acapella media for like straight up put what the girls said i have to admit
they could have like silently edited this stuff but they didn't so shout out again to acapella
media for this opportunity um what's one thing you want people to remember you about you and me
individually or as a generation uh like indulges or a generation as a generation oh as a generation
these girls are all so nice and they deserve the best treat them kindly please they're more than
just silly me oh thank you and me what what kind words truly what do you want to represent in the
vtuber sphere in megers my little embers i want to represent myself i want the boys to have fun
and be cute and i also want to represent honesty even if it makes people want to drop with me
for the things i'm honest about yes i agree with that i agree i agree i agree um i'm like i'm like
properly reading it for the first time like yeah yeah i put base answers yeah uh is there
event in vtuber history that was pretty uh particularly significant for you embers there is
but i won't say what it was but it made me realize that i'm worth what i'm worth and that i can get
where i want myself i'm still working on getting to where i want but at least i know i can do
huh i don't know what that's about not gonna lie i'm new to vtuber stuff well you have picked the
fucking worst agency to get started on we are the most like non-traditional vtuber agency but i'm
glad you can enjoy the veal or talons we basically do nothing the way you're supposed to do it but
thank you again for checking us out you mean a bit welcome to the best agency well in terms of a
traditional agency we do everything wrong you know like paying them their worth uh it's terrible
anyway thank you so much emmy for that interview i'm not really sure what happened to your voice
think you're partying too hard with your family or something like that i don't know yeah that's why
it sounds like this okay that's good mercy moddy's up you come mercy moddy's let's listen to your
voice and see if i can mimic it and the answer is gonna be no because i know for a fact i can't mimic
your voice oh wait hold on hold on oh mercy did a hand question yesterday wake up senpai senpai wake up
oh you're still a bit dizzy that's okay i hit you on the head pretty hard i hit you on the head
pretty hard you're not that nasally mercy i promise you you're not that nasally right mercy moddy's
the dark agandery up you come with the most outrageous outfit if you consider were you
designed correctly at this stage nope you were not no nail polish identified no band aids on the fingers
identified that is how you know this was designed was not finalized at this stage okay it means on
vacation our connection is breaking up clearly that that's why yes no no yachts for the owners oh no
oh truly a tear is in my eye thinking about uh me bragging about the return on investment yesterday
oh yeah that's right sorry we estimate return on investment after six months um talk about over
estimation anyway veal uh dear mercy veal lure is the first agency of its kind why did you choose
instead of remaining independent now let's just try one more time up an atom bomb i heard you wanted
to get to know me better while the allure may be uh agency first of its kind in the end i auditioned
due to detail's dream resonating with me there are many factors at play as well i was reaching my
dreams with my friends those who made it into other corporations so that i could stamp aside them
i'm happy to be here oh mercy i'm glad you accepted you could have said no to me you could have said
no in the interview and you still said yes thank you mercy how important was the amount of freedom
with with content creation being open to discussing private lives and stuff so i brought my special
love diary for me i don't want it i'm so sorry mercy for me i don't want to talk why have you
for a say go away mercy and you come for me i don't want to talk why am i going to a say by
default what the heck with all the information about me that you need to know so we can be together
forever for me i don't want to talk about my pl in particular but being given the choice is great
this is not going well my uh this is um i can't do it as soon as the girls like start being canadian
american specialized i can't do it i can't do it right hold on hold on all right what voice are we
gonna give mercy instead right let's give her the mickey mouse voice let's go for me i don't want to
talk about my pl in particular but being given the choice is great my peers do not have to hide who
they were and their old fans don't have to go to on hunt i'm a bit of a traditionalist so i still
want to keep it on the down low with veal or the freedom with content creation is more lenient
and i get to play the games i want and everything is more streamlined for more crucial things don't
get it twisted though i still get told no sometimes and that's a little good for me because sometimes
my ideas are bad or would be a brand risk oh wait no a bad risk that's why management is there oh
thank you mercy for answering that yes i can't believe it you actually got told no when did
he tell you no the fuck did we tell you no for i don't even know what platform did you want to
make content on prior to this mercy oh oh twitch youtube and fensley that's all i had in mind
prior to veal or fensley oh man uh once fired you to create that kind of content or that content
in general mercy i used to be an actor i actress whoops i've been unlucky for a lack of better
words for a while now i'm probably the most inexperienced of the group as this is my first
time really creating that kind of content to me it's a return to form while still exploring my
more sensual side haha it's been great fun also a roguet i play a roguet yeah oh wow mercy what the
heck is going on in your voice this is making me very gentle um while we're at it mercy do you
have any advice for a content careers safely navigating the 18 plus field remember internet
safety you learned in high school and i mean it that's really important i cannot stress enough
about how important it is to do your new diligence to keep yourself safe also if you do want to do
some if you don't want to do something say no yes that is very true please bring up any issues with
any things you might not want to do in an audio with us and make you finding his central side
children what do you hope to bring or change in the vtube and landscape mercy i hope feel or shows
that we are just like any other vtuber agency just with spicier content on the side that content is
by choice and if you want to interact with it i hope the taboo of being a not safe or vtuber goes
away because in the end like all other vtubers we just want to make you smile and entertain you
whoa steady on mercy steady on again you're really getting into the character there um
so can you read mario maros in mickey moise's voice as well you want that that's terrible is there
anything is there any alt content you're particularly interested in making in mercy mouse
mercy mouse i'm still discovering what i like and don't like so i'm exploring all facets of the
alternative content i'd like to try experimenting with the medium a little more but we're all we're
still in the beginning stages so taking it slow is okay okay but what do you want to represent
in the vtuber sphere mercy let us know let us know your thoughts this is a thought-provoking
question i suppose that i want to be at least someone who is seen as safe to work with even
though i make that kind of content as well i it doesn't define me and means i'm some what
it doesn't define me and means i'm some sort of rabid animal that cannot control my urges hot
i've losing it i'm actually going schizophrenic right now it was one thing that you want people
to remember about you mercy individually or as a generation my laughter and my personality but
for indulge i'm just i'm still a newcomer that's learning just i'll do you know shebe's getting
jesse from pokemon deal deal shebe's getting x already know i can't do shebe's voice for
shit shebe's getting jesse from pokemon ask you little twerp um is there a significant event in
vtuber history uh to you as a whole i suppose that the debut of hololive english really brought
out about the forefront of vtuber into an international audience as a whole it's no longer
a medium that is pretty niche it's becoming more and more acceptable i agree with that there was
very interesting discourse discord discourse around a year ago that was like vtuber's dying
i don't know if people still say that but i don't think people under oh my hands just farted if you
because they're sweaty um there was a bit of internet discord sorry mercy thank you so much
for your interview i really do appreciate it haha you're welcome thank you thank you um yeah there's
a lot of internet discourse doing that vtuber's dying v tripping is dying and it's like no you
don't understand this medium is perfect for a hell of a lot of people a lot of people don't
want to like pop their face out or be like basically abused for their looks when obviously you then
he's spawning knowing what you've done for your looks um agreed every day we stray further what
there's hundreds of beaches it's just more fragmented yeah strongy sway imagine the smell
thank you mousy modis oh thank you for having me i really appreciate that okay who's up next on
the chopping block she be condom her tail isn't present and you can tell that this is her older
design because she actually has lace on the top of her thigh house um her lines her ropes are lines
which um a lot of artists whenever i commissioned she be a lot of artists make her ropes lines and
i'm like no little funker make the texture rope okay make it rope mercy didn't even say bye to
senpai hold on a minute oh i'm back again oh bye senpai i'm snippets i can't wait to stream to
you later please don't forget to watch the vod of my one month celebration it is my first
hand cam stream oh thank you thank you that's perfect okay she be cotton bomb up you comey
come come i'm gonna give sorry i'm gonna give you a shot but let's be honest it's not happening
because her voices aren't hello hi there hello sweetheart hello my name is she be cotton bomb
i'm my name is she be cotton bomb you're mistress i'm the mistress i guess it's right jesse from
pokemon let's go as you twerk the bum dominatrix of via lures the first agency of oh i've just noticed
the misprint oops um that's my bad my bad chief um via lures the first oh wait that's the question
asked me asking it to her via lures the first agency of this kind she be why did you choose it
instead of being an independent as you twerk it's nice having the freedom of being an independent
reach over but i longed for a group of people that i could see as sisters and have a a consistent
collab partners with similar likes i'd also follow the roadmap of via lures for over a year
and shared a lot of the same aspirations as the creative mind behind it all strut stop you're
making me blush the fuck the fuck you're making me blush what the heck i also wanted to grow as a
creator and learn more about the industry and i couldn't do that without a little bit of help
now i have the resources amazing gen mates new knowledge and still manage to have talent freedom
i'll stop it you're blowing art you're blowing air up my arse like that i'm gonna get an eagle
stroke could these girls have stroke the agency anymore i didn't even direct them they did this
themselves okay how in she be was reading the question to herself because uh because good dogs
don't speak hey whoa i'm a dog what's going on here are you starting to insinuate so your
sponsor ash that's that's how that's how i do a prompt get into the voice okay how important
was the amount of freedom on content creation being open to pl etc for you i was ash who twerk i was
extremely attracted to the fact that feel lower broke a lot of standard reach over roles but pl
discussion wasn't a deal breaker for me also if i went in to sign the contract and felt like my
rights as a creator were being taken away um in any fashion i would never have signed on yeah
they all say that it's the most pathetic contract i've ever seen uh no matter the agency i do have
to say ash out of professionalism i still double checked with my management to ask permissions
because it's always good to make sure i mean that's pretty much melted away at this point that was
probably right at the start when the girls were unsure how much they're allowed to do
but i had to keep reminding the girls like hey you don't need permission go go don't need permission
go there can i tweet this go send it as long as it's on the right twitter account send it you
don't need permission but this was written a bit earlier so some of the stuff is about me
how can you not stroke the agency when instead of working for the agency the agency works for them
honestly sorry my glakes have got a fucking me mark on them right ash from pallet time come on
no no no ash uh jesse from pokemon come on i can do this i can do this okay and then no more accents
okay um ash would work it's really refreshing however to still feel like an indie you'd have
a team that has my back and supports me with whatever creative endeavor i've put my silly mind
to oh she be stop it my little sheepster's room oh sorry i'm covering up chat sorry sorry sorry chat
sorry i'm dumb oh hold on a bit uh what platforms did you want to make content prior to join
in v alert so when you were just doing your thing i was always the casual twitch streamer oh not
twitch andy and i hoped someday i could go full time adjusting to youtube has been interesting
but i don't mind it it's probably funny for me to say but i was never going to do anything
my pl like i'm doing now what's that corruption arc yeah you're welcome ash i wasn't going to
make a patreon or even consider fansly i see this reincarnation and my previous version of myself
as almost two sides of the same coin i can be your angel or your devil it's very cool to learn how
other platforms function and how you can develop and expand your audience alongside your main platform
oh wait did she see the angle oh my god is that why it was spelled weird i can be your angle or your
devil bro i thought i was like why the f*** did she spell it like that but everything else was
spelled correctly my dumb ass didn't read it right uh so she stares what inspired just make that kind
of content or that content in general just content in general okay it is the meme it's definitely the
i can be your angel or your devil uh i've always wanted to be a content creator since
watching youtubers like jenna marbles markiplier i'm not even saying that i wanted to have the same
positive effect on viewers that watching my favorite content creator had on me and still do
as for the erotic content i've always been indifferent about it i have dabbled extremely
briefly in the past in the raw and erotic content what it really got nowhere so i never
continued with it ash and now i have to learn and improve from the best of the best i'm not
uh is there any other content you're particularly interested in making
i'm not saying that name though i'm not saying the name of the content creator because i just know
with my accent it's gonna be 10 times worse if someone just cropped the first like me saying
the first part of that person's name it's over it's over for me in german is it over for mesh
yeah yeah it's over for mesh okay it's over um uh is there any how did i do that to the batman
theme okay anyway is there any content you're particularly interested in making it i really
want an opportunity to voice and uh loot animation are you joking me someone contacted the website about
that and i didn't reply i don't know if it's too late to reply hold on hold on i need to write a
note in the discord hold on i didn't realize she wanted to do that and someone contacted the website
and i was like oh the girls don't have enough time for that well i didn't reply but uh i need to write
a note like right now and hopefully we can grab that freaking thing um um uh um um uh what do i do
she be uh fucking animation voice over offer email somewhere find it asap uh in case time expired
because she actually wanted to pursue that whoopsies sorry she be i might have a job for you very
shortly sorry sheeps sorry sheepsters that was my bad my bad but we got we got we got it now
we got it now we got that we okay right hold on wait back back back back um yeah a little
ash from pal ash twerp when i get a 3d model i would like to take up poll lessons and share
my progress with viewers damn sheepsters going all out do you have any advice for people who
want to create 18 plus content yes advice advice any advisors any advisors did you literally write
that yep i have a note on my discord and i just spam there and whatever um the most ash twerp the
most important thing is please do not let the hate or negativity get to you it's not worth the stress
you little twerp there is something out there that will not gel with there what there is someone out
there that will always not gel with you or your content and that's okay you do not have to cater
to everyone do what you're comfortable with and do not feel pressured if you need to limit interaction
with people who get pushy don't be afraid to hit that mute or block button damn sheepsters she for
the thorough how do you always start with ash twerp so in the va say the things in order to get
into a character's voice you can give yourself a prompt that is my prompt to do jesse from pokemon
i can't do it naturally and what do you hope to bring or change in v tubing landscape i hope that
companies consider the transparency of our splits and make adjustments accordingly in favor of the
talents if they have the profit v tubing is an ever-growing industry and towns deserve a bit more
for the work that they oh my god preachy be are we taking down the high table together and i
i'll take them the high table with you any day okay what's one thing you want people to remember
about you sheepsters individually or as a generation of dealer as a company we're breaking the status
quo of what it means to be a corporate vtuber you can allow and manage alternative content
you can talk about your pl if you want and you can have a human relationship with your talents
instead of treating them like far oh oh tell her is she be like fodder and still be a successful
company as a generation a group of girls that just want to have a group of girls that just
want to have fun make you happy and we appeal to all if not many in some way shape or form
and then you can hire unknown oh that's so cute and and sorry and that you can hire unknown talent
there's a few gems out there oh my god i'm gonna agree a few of us were complete nobodies but
someone saw our potential no it gave us a chance what the fuck i'm saying no that's so sweet i'm
thankful for that as myself your favorite girl failure scuff dorky scuff dorky dog always root
for the underdog i'm not kidding always root for the underdog hold on let me let me recalibrate my
model i'm looking a bit funny i'm looking a bit skew if okay there we go recalibrate oh
oh blow and smoke up your butt is supposed to be our job literally let me repeat that last
bit uh you can hire unknown talent there's a few gems no there's lots of gems out there it just
ain't easy the problem it's kind of like a self-fulfilling prophecy unhidden gem thinks
they're not good enough to apply to vtuber agency don't apply don't get shown off type thing
it really can be as simple as that there's like a lot of like i remember we got emailed on the
website after closing applications and someone was like i'm so sorry i've missed the window because
i didn't feel like worthy enough to apply and it was like bro you missed your deadline if we can't
we can't make exceptions but it's like don't hold yourself back seriously the talent pool is massive
it is like it's beyond comprehension how many little hidden gems are out there and they just
need a running start they just need like that exposure they need someone you know with the money
that can be like okay here's shorts right upload them right here's a bit of advertisement money
in this here's in that yeah it's a self-propagating issue where the lack of confidence is your work
yeah the imposter syndrome yeah and fear of rejection as well as absolutely humongous barrier
for some people it really is um you know i'm not gonna sit here and be like oh i don't experience
that so i'm not gonna you know be say xyz about it um it is this is a big thing anyway uh sorry
she be to ramble over it's fine um thank you uh what do you want to represent in the vtuber
and spear sheepsters um i think i've represented in my content enough already oh man oh we love
a confident dump but that you can still make 18 plus content and still be a normal streamer on
common part horrors some have the idea that lute tubers are coomed brain 24 7 and flick their
beads on stream and do nothing else haha wait wait would that be like a milk laugh i got uh
haha no that's not what the fuck is a milk laugh hold on hold on i'm gonna literally tape in milk
laugh on youtube and see if anything comes up uh nope nothing came up well i tried um
and what is a milk laugh oh i don't know something like that uh i still act like my dorky self play
games and create other content like everyone else i'm just an added what it's just an added bonus
i moan in your ear on patreon wink wink please support the girls on patreon we're undercutting
the fucking mark yet please i'm begging i'm on my knees but i'm begging begging you
okay as they're an event in v tripping history that is significant to you my dear sheepsters
yes or no the creation of project melody a melody was the catalyst in my opinion of the boom of
lute tubers she pushed the boundaries of 18 plus content but still displayed herself as a cute and
talented streamer a normal human being but also a friendly vtuber with a unique approach to 3d
i can safely say she is a pioneer in not only on say so content creation but audience interaction
and streaming and in general thanks thank you melody fantastic thank you so much sheebie
for your fantastic okay um right i'm gonna thank you i'm gonna let you go rest because you
don't have a stream today question mark i really need to download everyone's things all at once so i
can start pulling up and be like right who this is who's coming on the day thank you so much sheepsters
up next who we got
right i'm interviewing myself let's go right let's go let's go let's get hype hype man look at that
look at that design so my design was actually finalized at this stage um kind of as you can
see i've got pearlescent if you didn't know i shimmer i don't actually have white on my outfit
i'm pearlescent check out wait hold on check out this oh hold on that's my stream deck oh hold on
that's the wrong one see i'm all wiggly and pearly essencey okay that's what i look like
but i'm scrawny cut oh it's a hypnotic cut of fish that has been streaming for a month and has
yet to put out one piece of hypno content other than a live stream uh and i did it for like 40
minutes and never did it any longer so obviously the first question did not apply to me vealour is
the first agency why did you choose it nope man man's was pre-selected so that question does not
apply to me so i had to get creative and give myself an alternative question and i've already
lost the damn magazine hold on i have found the magazine okay how did you attract independent
v-tubers to vealour is the only question substituted for me okay so first getting our name out there
was a challenge but we got incredibly lucky on youtube and the algorithm tapped into the reveal
trailer the announcement of vealours all the way back at new years is just shy of 100 000 views on
youtube okay and i'm going to discuss that in a short because there's a reason why i got picked up
in the algorithm then the vealour website stated what we wanted i cooked on that website okay i set
it straight up i said this is the cut this is the expectations there was no oh i don't know what i'm
signing up for oh i don't know i don't know no we set it off the bat so the people that did apply
knew what they were getting into okay so there really wasn't a struggle like as i said the talent
pool was pretty big considering new vtuber agency founding members uh quite a few different rules
most vtuber agencies are like eh you didn't have to make content prior to applying yeah they shove
your shit in the bin if you don't have any evidence so okay and yet there's people still asking
questions honestly that's not i'm wearing marathon runners why yes of course you don't sound like strawny
how dare you what you want to make my accent harsher okay so how important was the amount of freedom
content discussing pls etc although i confess it's not traditional and may lead to a few people not
enjoying what vealour have to offer he'll offer probably i'm no here to pretend that gen one
indulges made up of people who have never streamed before is this what you want yeah actually all of
the girls had more streaming experience than me this is true so it was quite funny going through
applications in that sense it was rather humorous it was humorous okay uh thank you strawny for the
next question what platform did you want to make content prior to vealour right youtube has always
been a staple for many eyes and i have found overall that their rules are mostly fair bad the
bloody uh this this age terribly this age terribly we all have warnings for breathing in an ear
anyway twitch however seems to have issues with using rules to punish some but not others it is
more of a pick the lesser of two evil situation twitter or x is much more for an overall promotion
and connecting with other vtubers for collaborations i'm afraid personally i'm just no suited for
twitter outside of that and i'm just i'm shy on twitter what inspired you to create alternative
content or content in general i never personally okay had any issues where it's just another media
source you either wish to consume it and seek it out or you just deny at all i suppose in my case
due to how comfortable i am where i find it quite fascinating to learn about what people enjoy and
challenge myself to give them what they want and that's true i like i like when you guys tell me
something outrageous and i'm like bet all right let's do it let's do it let's do it we need a scotland
forever okay i'll make scrawny say scotland forever at the end of the interview okay um
is there any content you're particularly interested in making it in the all alternative version
i have always had a secret fascination about hypnosis but i am well aware of the safety concerns
that come first it is with this new breath of life that the allure has offered me that i can finally
go down this rabbit hole and see what happens this is actually true um i've always enjoyed hypnosis
but being absolutely terrified to make it do you have any advice for people who might want to come
into safely creating a content of an alternate variety delete everything related to your legal
name and social media under it that is rule one okay chase louise from there be on the side of caution
now sadly you are an adult and you are responsible for your actions no matter how foolish they may
have been in the moment please do not think however you will be the only numpty on planet earth
to make a mistake that is only natural so do not be harsh on yourself you will say and do stupid
things that is life okay relax no that's serious all right okay thank you started streaming 69 minutes
ago i am oh yeah what do you hope to bring to or change in the vtubing landscape on the surface
on the surface the answer would be that the western vtuber agencies are those agencies
that wish to appeal to these western agencies also understand that comes with culture changes
for example more freedoms of course the scottish person says more freedoms you can take my life
but i can't take my freedom honestly most freedoms less restrictions as a whole on vtuber agencies
stop being greedy gifts and pay your talents what they earned you did not earn that wake up
you didn't earn it you weren't the one streaming you weren't the one putting the hours in pay your
talents higher than 50 percent that's all i'm fucking asking stop doing less than 50 percent
it's disgusting thank you anyway that's me um anyway now that i've passed that along uh oh you
got a bit passionate there strony i do apologize okay okay let's go next um what's one thing that
you want people to remember about you individually or a generation individually it is uh is to be
yourself unironically and unapologetically as a generation well who better to indulge in than us
oh thank you get it because our uh our gen name is indulge oh oh sorry was i not to explain it
oh i'm sorry okay sorry sorry uh i'll see myself out oh well oh well i'll try my best uh what do
you want to represent in the vtuber sphere stronzo uh that you do not have to know everything
to be accepted into the vtuber community okay i could have easily uh what's going on here pan up
fishing what you said
i have absolutely terrible news i do not speak whatever language that is uh let's open up google
docs thank you for the 20 pan optician uh let's sorry google translate i'll take the google translate
hold on hold on come on google translate come on you can do it you can do it it's a russian national
anthem no all right okay russia our great power russia our beloved country the mighty world a great
glory your property for all time your property for all time no it's it's not communism communism
doesn't work because of greedy our souls but we can get close to it natibia oh and of course
sister fucking pops up as soon as russians mentioned okay dude and okay that's it that's it
that's it you're done we got freedom okay do you see that cute cuttlefish do you see the cute
cuttle fishery flings that's my kami off you cola oh narrow thank you for the tip and the compliment
and pan option thank you for the ridiculous tip okay this then comes in as soon as the russians
are mentioned we got freedoms around here partner uh what do you want to represent oh i was halfway
saying to that sorry okay uh that you didn't have to know everything to be accepted by the vtubing
community i could have easily have been chewed up and spat back out but instead was welcomed with
open arms for my curiosity and wanting to learn more it has led to various uh humorous moments
such as tisker which is short for tisker it now is being called tisker in my community because
i didn't know what it meant and again i didn't know what that so meant and you guys were just so
nice and taught me everything um and i think it's because like you know you can uh yeah did you
take yeah and fucking okay you're done i still say tisker though literally tisker mentioned any
tisker yeah um we say instead of tisker or tskr tisker um is there any significant event in vtubing
that is incredibly important to you um the uprising of creator-owned vtuber agencies is upon us now
okay um socks agencies a fantastic example yumi plus i think is technically an example
um having someone at the helm that has had experience of what and knows what it's like
um to produce content and uh knows what to expect is very exciting i can't wait to see more agencies
come out that are like that and you never know viola might just collaborate with them i sure it is
i hope you're okay yes we are uh it should wink wink but yes um i think creator-owned vtuber
agencies are fantastic because they're realistic and like they know what's up they're like i've
made content before i know what like kind of strange you're under um kind of like is a split
hollow live collab no what i don't have you think i have contacts for hollow live the fuck
the fuck as if we as if they'd even let us collab they'd be like oh those are darties
no having it anyway thank you so much uh strong zoo for your uh interview
skull and forever okay well that was very weak um yeah i'm still feeling a bit tired i'm gonna be
honest i'm not sure i can just go skull and forever yeah i'm not really got it and before
hollow live mentions you guys there is zero chance of a hollow live even noticing as far as i'm aware
unless one of the girls just like fucking exponentially blows up ma ma ma um although that
would be outrageous because of her lore wow we did it we read through oh wait hold on actually let me
put this back up but i'm gonna make it smaller i wish it was a little bit smaller i wish it was
a baller i wish i had a rabbit in a hat with a bat in a baseball bat or something like that
do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do right and then i'm gonna put myself
over here oh my god i actually did it i didn't ramble for like seven hours we actually got
through the magazine check us out i have been indulged indulges all over you never has a high
change i shall contact the gods to rearrange it honestly um yes we're on a magazine uh and
it wasn't the magazine that you have to pull out and open and then like an extra page drops
there no it's like an actual magazine yay get it it's not one of those magazines
give me that cloning journey bruv disgusting disgusting sense that's disgusting thank you to
all the girls for taking time to come yes thank you uh uh thank you emmy hi welcome uh it's totally
no cream from sonic heroes thank you ac uh what's i see you're welcome i'm going back to my dad
does now okay okay that's good that's good thank you i say uh thank you merci oh what the f*** why
do i sound like mickey mouse sorry mercy couldn't mimic you but thank you nonetheless uh she be uh
shoot work thanks for having me on these interview let's go and then last but not least as early
oh thank you stony minister only super heavy me yay let's go um let's go merci is gonna be mickey
i couldn't do merci's voice so she became mickey mouse rip rip and piss sorry sorry ko hi sorry senpai
uh but yeah great interview yes thank you girls for making it i don't know how our schedules
really synced up so well there but uh you didn't thank strony oh thank you strony ah
no problem no problem that's on me that was a pleasure that was not but short about a pleasure
um goodbye merci mouse honestly um 10 out of 10 collab i'm glad you enjoyed it truly um right now is
when i link my marshmallow because you guys are allowed to ask me questions
about anything and i will answer what i can answer q and a here we go do you have a link
to the magazine it's pinned right now believe it or not uh thank you again pan option for your 20
i assure you that money is going into the reservoirs of of what ah well why is it prompting me to buy
my own super chat no i just wanted to make sure i was saying isn't he right play uh replace pinned
message okay let's go boom you can ask me any question obviously i have the right to not answer
if it's like it's a bit too much but um at the stage in time peeler mentioned a bloody op not
bloody op not timed it for a joke don't know sadge no i didn't time what i didn't time you out
every quick no not every question in the world i'm not like some all-knowing being um
but yeah uh i am going to take a drink of water i i urge everyone to have a hydration a little
hydration um i love it i love it water's so good the way it hydrates my throat and stops me from
having a coffin fit delicious 10 out 10 every question what is the meaning of life page very
base scottish person indeed but you talk like an old wise god do i super chat yourself to give yourself
money so we uh veal or mod what's going on here what have you done what have you done veal or
mod we saw that she isn't all-knowing that's a months loving honestly do you prefer your water
cold or room temperature a wee bit too late a wee bit too late right hold on let me refresh the
marshmallows um i am going to be reading them off my monitor i'm not gonna have them displayed
what was the removed mercy line if you're at liberty to say um she said something about
self-deprecating and it was a bit it was a bit on the severe side so i rephrased the sentence
to be nicer to herself um she used a phrase that wasn't very friendly but uh i'm not gonna say the
exact phrase because that's not very nice but uh yeah i think she'll i'm i'm sure she'll be fine
with it um wait what top bottom switch views are bosoms bosoms female female male male male female
what the heck you've just blasted right into it uh wait is that what i am
i just blasted into it uh it was maybe we'll come you know we'll come back to come back to it okay
uh moment i love you replaying i love you did you like me doing all the impressions it's a very
deep question what are oh hold on right hold on hold on what are some ways companies can
companies set up right whoever sent this question one using spell check and two i can't read properly
what are some ways companies can set up stuff so the company itself can protect their talents
fun set aside for legal concerns taxes content eight screenshots platform liaisons
anti anti stuff teaching the ropes um i think just being realistic like if you have been a
content creator and then you're behind the scenes you know what the girls are up against like um
obviously we shut down the marshmallows for quite a bit because like a few of the talents
were having issues and like i guess that was like a measure to basically we took on we got the girls
feedback and we were like nah forget this you're done so um and we were like right everyone off
marshmallow right now don't reply don't do nothing we're fucked up we made a mistake
sure do love when the xbox servers are done have the servers down
okay if another idiot comes up with mirrors i'm gonna play doom in real nah
ah barely audible oh did i do a tiny little burp there i wasn't paying attention
um taxes again don't actually spend the money until you paid the tax you should always hold 30
percent back uh i guess if you want tax uh content aid so uh that's like collaborations with people
outside of the agency um that's like putting advertisement money in shorts for example so
we do something that i don't think any other agency really offers we pay for the shorts to be made
for the talents we make the thumbnails for them their schedules all that we try and give them at
least stuff possible they're obviously the only overwhelming problem is like i took a while to
find the editors and get settled with the editors like um a few of them couldn't do it a few of them
uh now currently have ongoing in real life obligations which caused a massive backlog
like that's why irisa is my personal clipper because um i was just having so many issues
and at the rate the shorts were being made it was like at one point one person was making all the
shorts and it was like no that's just not viable at all um but azura is next to get shorts and
then shebe's getting a batch and then i think by that point we will have four people who can make
clips on at the same time but a lot of in real life stuff happened in their lives which caused a
massive backlog and it's caused an issue because i would have wanted a lot more shorts out by now
i don't know for me it's a respect thing there are people at least try to treat them as proper
human beings and not circus freaks uh communication is key um what are you saying
stroney my muse my flame my 16th chapel my 5th sympathy symphony oh god you're making me say
big words my cute and adorable seaweed first happy one month happy one month even though it's
technically yesterday but happy one month hell yeah um it's been fun and i look forward to many
more oh yeah next i want to say i've already been mindbroken to where i can only ink to
no but i haven't done it yet oh wow coming in 16 minutes late watching from the start at
one point five times and hearing your impressions of the girls with certainly an experience thank you
mom oh you're your love you're welcome bro steano thank you for the the super chat and yes
you're welcome to i i'm gonna see i can't for the life of me to the others uh it was awful it was
terrible we had to switch up i have like two voices and that's the best i've all gone for me okay
um what is this wifling saying i've already brain broken so i can only ink to you but there
have been some developments i would like to share what more how you're corrupting me further
i've discovered more i need to be careful i don't know what you're about to say a little wifling
i've discovered more things about myself and ever since i heard you panting like a good pop
something without me changed oh no have i just let you down something in my brain activated and i
knew in that moment that i wanted to put a collar on you oh my god i would take care of you pet you
and or i'm not sure i can read this stuff oh no i would take care of you pet you and order you
wag your cute little tail um plugs just show me how you say it in ego you are oh my god wifling
i don't know if we can say this stuff out loud and of course i would reward you for being such a
good girl oh my god you can't say that he spoke the truth the sanest wifling of all you kicked him
like a well-done steak oh my god i was insane he's falling down the strony hole he's done for
just like me for real for real subspace type no you ain't got me this time i'm smiling like
ear to ear my cheeks hurt right now though just thought i'd send a funny meme on here
can't could you see say fellows did someone mention the door to darkness although your
mickey mouse voice is funny i want to hear it in your natural world oh sorry uh say fellas did
someone mention the door to darkness is that what you wanted hopefully i did that right i'm sorry i
don't know where that's a quote from i don't recall i don't recall what is this a quote
uh veiler fan calendar on team up super helpful for keeping track of upcoming streams it's actually
possible to embed the calendar into the website i don't know if we were gonna go on holodex soon
or not i think the first person has to reach 20k and then we could all be submitted so let me uh
let me be transparent and i'll work towards that however though it's a kingdom hearts it's a mickey
mouse kingdom hearts mickey mouse go say fellas did someone mention the door to darkness huh what the
i've never played kingdom hearts i'm sorry all i know is that there's one meme of this guy laughing
and he goes ha ha ha ha and that's that's all i know about kingdom hearts not a thing else
oh my god it sounded the same did it oh no disney's taking you down one goes
uh hi strongy you are not beating the allegations that you're actually all the girls yeah did you
like my mercy impression that was terrible um um hi strongy first of all i love you and veiler
well i love you and veiler loves you too take that okay and i wish you all the best and sending you
all the hugs in the world oh yeah you send me a hug that's me squeezing you you get squeezed get
squeezed back get wrecked okay second of all why have you and all the other girls taken comments
off on patreon uh we cannot moderate patreon efficiently um and we do not want any harassment
for the girls um so it's completely there you can't leave comments on posts if you want to
leave feedback for audios use their marshmallows that's the best i got okay that's the best i got
uh if you want to leave feedback but don't be an arsehole if you're no when i say leave feedback
only leave positive stuff then he'd be an arsehole come to me if you've got concerns but like please
remember a lot of the girls this is the first time they've ever recorded this stuff and and and and
and another note on another note we're not out here making shakespear okay these audios are to play
one hand did i make myself clear we're not out here to be shakespear okay you're here to shake
your spear to the audios okay so relax if there's a wee mistake in the background okay relax if you
can hear a bump because they bumped their desk while they're recording relax okay relax goodness
great some of you some of yous are running a muck i can tell you that mad or red thank you for
becoming a member i appreciate it there is a membership stream after the stream 20m
to shake your spear it's time i write a four page review on a literal analysis oh god honestly
um the shadows harassing moment honestly i haven't bought the shadow
can their girls use their live team or models for video content on patreon nope it is strictly
audio nothing else is getting posted on it for the safety and the security of the girls' income
sources i do apologize if that's this appointing news um
easter egg in emi's interview
is there shut up hold on stop wait a minute is there actually where is it
there's an easter egg in emi's interview hold on a minute how do you spot the interview
and i don't spot it where's hold on hold on
easter egg in emi's interview she used the phrase keep yourself safe kiss your sister where
keep yourself safe
on the internet safety part
don't compare some friends of people consume quite a certain keep yourself safe please
i don't i don't actually think that's an easter egg i think that's actually just
uh what she meant like genuinely keep yourself safe i don't actually think that's an easter egg
because she said please if it was an easter egg it would be keep yourself safe
no i think she may or may not have actually actually i don't think that's an easter egg
this month was fantastic thank you for everything you did and that you're doing
seeing how excited and happy you are makes me feel so good and honestly inspires me oh yeah
can you say how can you keep up with everything i think i would die in two seconds um so
i basically don't experience what people explain burnout to be
and the reason i don't experience it is thanks to autism i don't know how i got lucky with that
kind of autism but i did um i basically now don't get me wrong i can get frustrated and fatigued
but when i go to bed and then when i wake up it's like a fresh new day like let's go again
and one of the best things that i am able to do is i say to myself as long as i do one thing a day
so after i finish stream i say to myself i'll do one thing a day if that's editing an audio
collab if that's you know writing a script collab or something like that um as long as i do that
then you know we're on the up and up that's all i need to do um just one thing a day um maybe i can
impart that wisdom to you with that phrase and just say one thing a day doesn't matter how big
or small it is like if you are a bed rotting max or that one thing a day can literally be brushing
your teeth and then roll back in a bed one thing a day that's it all you got to do one thing a day
um that's uh the reason why i can do it to end others might not be able to
uh can we send save for work bibbutes on marshmallow yeah how does catbox work also
um it's like a website you put your link in it and then you send me the link here
what's the news on a new set of emotes uh any og sands
is there any og sands that noticed ic has new emotes huh
huh emmy's new emotes are the next one on the way i'm waiting for uh confirmation that
mercies have been ordered i noticed a lot of hearts yeah one thing a day has been my philosophy
for a long time then you have fantastic philosophy unironically it is a bed rotting max or yeah like
you can get pheromone max or see that's myself not beating the high wisdom allegations that's not
wisdom mythic pool honestly mythic pool not to some combination honestly um depression max and
yeah if you're depression max and you're one thing a day literally make your bed brush your
teeth get a glass of water something like that that's that's all you need to do the new ic emotes
are amazing yes emmy's are up next up on the chopping block um i will be putting placeholders
in their emotes so you'll notice a ton of hearts um that is because emmy has eight hearts that's
because emmy i say sorry has eight hearts that's because she can already order eight more emotes
thanks to all the membership uh tier support that you guys are showing her so she's already got
eight new ones she can order she just needs to tell me what she wants um where is mummy
you said this an hour ago i was live on stream with you reefling what do you mean you missed me
i was right here mummy i've never done any backdoor stuff before but if it's for you i can make an
exception oh yeah would you let me i'll be gentle i promise you know you've got a special spot
that feels really good there come on let me do it what sort of what sort of figurine should a total
be get her flared base that's all i'm gonna say a flared base that's all you need all your flared
bases are belong to us okay all you need is a flared base don't do anything silly and use lots of
em is it w 40 yeah use a lot of that it's droney i love you i just wanted to say i love you too
a little reefling oh you say i love you i love you so much i love you so much reefling i want to
gush about it uh and about you but this is the only place i feel comfortable doing it yeah don't
worry don't you don't need to say anything you can be nice and quiet uh and marshy marlowe's okay so
don't worry the way you talk oh yeah you're like that's how you talk about anything that interests
you find a moment to tease it then end you end or something then go back to what you're talking
about it's so effortlessly hot you're so smart i wish i wish you could do all the thinking for me
whoa talk about uh corrupt and yeah don't mind if i do i love you love you little reefling i'm glad
i could corrupt you like that yeah you like my little rants when i find a subject i like and i'm
like oh i have knowledge of this subject let me dump this knowledge on you have fun being hypnotized
reeflings i shall join again when i can love you thanks for joining little beefland see you later
alligator uh if you're getting an insertion device you don't want to explain how you fell on it
uh
all right okay someone says mome give me your panties uh sure uh yippie marsh mellows are back
before i send anything else i just want to reiterate once again how lucky we are to have you as our
kami oh she and yes you damn well are that so stop it the way you push yourself to couldn't
consistently grow and learn as a source of inspiration to everyone around you and the
love care and understanding shows amazing if mommy has a million reeflings i'm one of them
if mommy has five reeflings i'm one of them if mommy has one reefling that's me and i'm
i'll exhaust myself to breed you wow to breed you as many times as you want until we are a
million strong once more and you and can share are you in love hey this this reefling's gonna
repopulate all the reeflings what the heck i didn't know where that was going i had no idea where that
was going oh it's so whole so that's like a deter okay let me refresh let me refresh oh that's a
lot more uh marsh mellows whoops um uh i might far i don't know i'm not decided yet i've not
decided i'm gonna i do a little a little far for you all right fuck it i'm gonna force it
all done that one's for you thoughts on warhammer fortunately i'm not educated enough to actually
formulate a thought on the the franchise but i am glad you enjoy it okay i'm so glad you enjoy it
don't say it in that tone oh yeah i just farted congrats on the one month well congrats on your
one month of being able to know about uh my gen mates because they're so awesome and cool and
everything's cool when you're part of the team i'm just glad the funding for everything is way
better than you well there is air coming out both ends of me right now what the heck
i'm glad the funding for everything is way better than expected just wanted to ask a random question
do you have a favorite cat breed right now this is wrong of me because i don't believe in cat breeds
that are not nice to the cat but i have to admit if you have ever seen a cat with no tail it looks
so fascinating and different it looks like a capybara but i guess that's not a cat breed
um you said yours is a le yoy a le yoke a le yoke le yoke what is your
what is your favorite looking cat are you serious oh what's your favorite looking cat
fucking golem oh wait sorry i'm not going to do it on that one because that's a terrible idea
uh right add no no no slide show don't go stop it slide show you're embarrassing me stop
and it doesn't play now
bruh magazine please magazine stop do not change okay don't do that again i'm getting
controlled by a freaking magazine uh this is the absolutely hideous create new cat uh make
a source desktop i'm getting oh honey you didn't hear that all right annam goes this is my favorite
cat uh all right golem lover all right then that's your favorite cat it looks like a werewolf
and golem like combine look how yellow and i didn't like naked cats sorry it freaks me out when
their fur isn't like all soft and that i'm a tabby cat golem girl confirm you're done
i'm a tabby cat lover love me tabby cats i love cats that have good genetic pool because it's good
for the genetic i bit you audio oh yeah you want me to listen to it right now could you imagine if
i was oh it's a video i tend to add to my collection um will the jar be included when
you collect figures come out sir sir will the jar come out with the collectible figures come out
you want viola to come out with collectible figurines i am dming bad dragon right now
hi strongy it's been a lot of fun watching you guys stream oh yeah i'm glad you guys
enjoy it i believe i've inked you've tallied it i've inked a total of 23 times give or take
during your streams how
during how how how do you do it during
did you do it to cameo
did you do it to baltro be honest
rafling rafling 23 times whilst i'm streaming on another note i would love to hear you say
one of my favorite dark souls quotes bear seek seek less did i did i do it thank you for all your
content and for more in years to come oh yeah they really like your asmr streams he missed seven
days that's a get out how dare you hi strongy just wanted to see me and my wife oh have really been
enjoying all the girl streams even if we don't really interact that much with the ludeness you
still appreciate the comfy course of it oh thank you hi annan's wave hi hi annan hi i'm glad you
like the content sorry that we're sometimes really despicable though but hi what what do you call a
javelin thrower with parkinson's shakespeare yeah you're done you're done for that submission
whoever submit that you should feel very ashamed of your right now she just called them annan's and
not reefland oh i guess reefland's then yeah i don't know well it's because it's anonymous on
marshmallow i feel like if you're talking in marshmallow then it's annan but i guess it is
reefland's as well hi reefling and reeflings wave sorry mmm good jobs on everyone so far
why thank you are there plans or considerations for fully alternative models um at this point
in time no we are already i'm gonna be honest um the uphill battle we've had with azura and shebe
has humbled me a bit um at this point in time the answer is no there's no plans for it now don't
get me wrong that can always change um but you know it's kind of like well where'd you put it
bansley well two of your girls can't even do that well then what's the point you know i really
don't want it to be unfair whereas like some get that toggled some don't i don't know i don't know
i need to check fan i need to uh bansley sorry you can't bansley bansley wink wink bansley um
scottish mother is streaming again oh yeah i'm answering marshmallows if you have any questions
you're welcome to ask away is this the complaints department damn straight is hold on we're we're
short we don't have the shadow box this is real i would like to file a complaint mm-hmm that there are
six lovely girls oh girls i've been stealing all my time and attention oh please do something about
this my heart can only beat so fast and they keep making it race please and thank you oh thank you
i was getting red did you hear how angry i was at the start of that and then as soon as i read six
lovely girls my voice changed oh that's so sweet thank you um that was so nice oh my god someone's
doing are you doing fake scottish what you think scottish people sound like if i if i take the lads
to gregs and write a story about it day a target m greg are you making an m pregnant joke with gregs
the fucking british bakery franchise if i take the wrote it in scott so they put if i take the lads
to gregs and write a story about it they have to tag it tag it is in gregs that's awful don't ever
cook again step away from the the kitchen let me take over because you're not allowed to cook again
do you understand me when was the last time um you screwed up and no one noticed i screw up all
the time my mech assault audio was so broken um the isaac my obs was breaking and lagging out my
model uh i screw up all the time i don't even hide my mistakes i'm i'm i'm humble maxing i don't
hide them because i'm just like yeah i'm human surprise surprise i'm not perfect becker thank
you for becoming a member so fancy we noticed we all noticed that oh well yeah oh didn't notice
oh i don't know i don't know the far oh yeah i farted in stream um it got picked up but no one
i think everyone thought it was my room cracking because like the walls crack sometimes
um yeah i've like straight up farted on stream yeah yeah yeah that's my answer
uh i don't think anyone's found it yet no one's timestamp commented
um my canadian friend keeps asking why my british friends for a video of him using a greg
using a greg so what you take the sausage out of the pastry and which stream timestamp no there's
no timestamp no one's found it yet i'm just starting i want to know
where would you like to time travel the past or the future unfortunately i'm a woman so the past
probably isn't that good but the future seems pretty gloom so i'll stick right here in this timeline
uh uh you know born too late to see something born too early to see the future born in the same
timeline the strony calls a hungry jacks or mackers uh i get the absolute a screaming
shite so if i get mackers for some reason so hungry jacks it is for some reason mcdonald's
uh breakfast i can eat but if i eat anything else off the menu it makes me have a lava flow
yeah rip
this is the best time future means i get to see all strone's vids but i won't be able to join the
streams oh that's like really sad though gregs is oh gregs is bad don't say such things reflings
next time you go to gregs you order cheese and hamburger well you don't order it you pick up from
the west side bit um and then you get uh sausage and cheese and bean pastry and you get the apple
juice that's what i used to get from gregs i don't like any other their bakery stuff like the sweet
stuff it's always rubbish we die on this hill no i don't i don't like the grill i like the sausage
and beans i really like beans though beans what is the wildest fantasy you've ever had um so there's
this concept called the asmr booth and it's it's growing arms legs it has hair it's probably got
brain cells at this point um basically i get to tingle you in person and put a mask on you and
like uh the joke is like you buy the premium pass at like a convention and then like i put you in the
soundproof booth with me and then things get out of hand really quickly okay um i've already wrote
a plot about that and i've already recorded it at the stage and hi cuddles i love you hi riefling
i love you thank you for the love here's your all-time celebrity crash bayonetta this bayonetta
account is a crash what would i do if i only had 24 hours to live is this a threat riefling what's
going on here as the hours pass i won't let you know um probably get my fairs in order i'd be like
right um sin sisters now the new owner of veal or she now owns it sorry it's your problem now sin
i can't be our stealing with it if i'm dead um right sin can own it that's fine what else
the girls get to own their ip's that's probably in a fair order um as for any money i earn um
my dad is being instructed to use it for his early retirement so he doesn't work himself into an
early grave uh what other stuff gimley and vego
gimley and vego sadly i don't want to stress them out and send them to scotland
thank you zarian for the tip brian why did you say it like that booth
are you squiddin me right now
asmr booth premium pause booth asmr be okay i like that sorry
dang i would be i would say goodbye to all the girls on veal or the pals you're not gonna die
yeah get my fairs in order uh gimley and vego might actually have to go back into a shelter
because i couldn't send them to scotland hmm right well let's uh let's not die uh let's not
die uh rather they don't go to a shelter because the poor things were in a shelter for long enough
uh what is the most embarrassing moment in all your childhood a projectile vomited in public
but it actually humbled me to the point where like i don't feel embarrassed going in public
like about anything if you have ever been so humbled to projectile vomit right with no privacy
then uh yeah it turns out you don't really get scared of going outside have i ever been arrested
oh just because i'm scotish i and i didn't sound posh you think i've been arrested and in trouble
with the polis well i don't know i've never been arrested uh but the polis are right arseholes
honestly um hello what's going on we're doing what's called a q&a on marshmallow and you can
ask anonymous questions hitting the bed hitting a bit what hitting a bed yen is something like
that would be a yes no i've been arrested are you joking uh can you give chat a smooch a smooch
pack her up did you like that
have the talents discussed uh in uh alternative collab audios yes uh next month is when the
first alternative collabs come out um it is a tip please understand that some of the girls have
only just started doing solo audios so to already jump into a collab audio is quite a high stretch
so please don't be weird and like this is so disappointing you think that's gonna be the only
one they'll ever make please i'm gonna i'm gonna throw up an anger shadow box and over here okay
rip i'm on speakers i'm so sorry please lower your volume of me that was uncalled for i think my
heart beat went up all of a sudden why is it that round pizzas come in square boxes for transport
mains um if you have a square box sitting on a car seat for example um it is more likely to stay
put and stay steady so transport much easier yes yes but if it was a circle imagine that thing rolling
around in the back seat get in that thing would be trashed by the time it got delivered um or you
took it back home if you go and pick up your what the fuck is that noise oh it's my chair sorry my
chair sorry i'm fucking out of my heart attack there we need good boys we need good um sorry this
one's i need to read it first before i say it i'll go that's so specific i don't think i can answer
that because it's related to the girls tea did you guys ever decide whether you're gonna use
bansley or not uh the girls can stream on it this month uh if they want to smile um i'm not
stopping them i need to give them their login details uh but i have never i don't have any i
don't know i'll let them figure it out and then i'll call for what they do because i actually have
never used the streaming service uh vealer has made me think about getting into v-tube and what
advice would you give someone delete all that shit delete every lick of your legal name online
delete every lick of a photo that you are not putting out delete delete everything uh don't
tell your parents that you're earning money um or your family that you're earning money uh just in
case they turn on you i've had so many horror stories of um girls telling me they told their
family they earned money and now they're in a horror situation where like they're the breadwinner
the family type thing a it's different if you want to offer the money but get in delete yourself
you literally made a short um did i make a short what do you think your last words will be um
um to be honest i'm probably gonna be dementia shitting myself in a care home uh so i'm not
really gonna i'm probably a mumbling mess i'll probably be like ah back to scotland i go well
wait no i'll die in scotland so i'll already be on it uh it'd probably be like oh that was fun
if i if i was coherent it would be that was fun like do you know how ridiculous it is and how
people would kill to be in my position to like mess around and have fun um and like literally i got
to play my childhood game yesterday and i got enraged by a piece of fruit uh like and i got
gamerscore and stuff um mumble something about the high table did i did i do it did i destroy it
and then the we care home workers like yeah yeah sure sure now let's get you into bread uh grandma
oh sorry my what is going on with my we hold on i need to recalibrate perfect strummer by the way
okay done done done and recalibrate
um well we can say that wait she has not that good of a memory we love you nonetheless
the last group hey strunzo quick question uh which way of the neton gets the least cut of
um that would be stream element yes i think it goes stream elements then it goes patreon and
then it goes youtube last which is funny enough oh my marshmallow broke so i can't scroll down
mommy help big gamble got me i can't stop playing baltro i'm sorry it's such a good it's such a
good game it really is um uh do you have any productivity or time management tips beside one
thing a day um i am a write it down kind of gal i write everything down that i need to do and like
so i can cross off and remind myself what i need to do that might work for you if you need visual
stimuli to tell you what to do next but basically you need to actually this is one of the really
big tips if you want to work hard and get a lot of stuff done okay um do you is you need to feel
your body this sounds ridiculous but it's true if you're using your brain and you're thinking and
your strategic doing strategies and all that you genuinely need to feel your brain in order to do
all these things it is not possible without eating so don't starve yourself don't forget to eat it is
so important for electrical brain activity to do it bang okay um hey stroney love your scotch accent
what accent in the world sounds the most attractive to me to me oh that's a hard question
i don't know if i want to be like stereotypical and haha to to baguettes but it's pretty stereotypical
um i can't even say that um that was the accent in bad the german accent german guys sound so
aggressive but their words are so gentle like you know i don't think i could pick that
um excuse me after 21 days i've created a new nightly habit what a collage of bibiutes shop
i'm opening this right now is this real 21 day am i about to look at 21 day collab of bibiutes
stop imagine if it is though oh no i fucked up the link oh my god i'm so dumb when it comes
you guys like link me the stuff and i still can't get it right oh my god no way i want to
show this on stream so badly don't worry there's no there's no there's no tentacle but there's
there's blotches on the paper with my face on it no way
oh my god wait it says alert devoted hypnotized worship controlled addicted enslaved
oh my gosh that was 20 that really was 21
that was a lot grief won't get out hello codles i don't really have a question that's a game i
have to have a question you go over but wanted to say that you unironically helped me a lot of
motivation to not do a self-delay yeah let's not control all four around these parts you've
you've only got one game of play you can pause it at any time but let's not let's not eject the old
cd drive you know the old disk drive in the xbox 360 uh you being you and your words made me realize
that my few successes are enough even the most insignificant ones so in a way you saved my life
keep being the lovable dork and amazing person you are thank you reefling yes um like playing
the video game of life is hard you can pause it at any time you can spawn in on the worst highest
difficulty ever and it can be absolute dope shit okay um but all f4 in that game no let's not that's
no that's not good you can pause the game okay you can pause the game and come back to it but
i'm glad uh there's no f4 in um that's not what what let to go on a completely different comment
directly after that okay what led up to the projectile vomit in public uh i ate something dodgy
yes i ate something dodgy and then i went out in public and i could tell something was wrong
but when uh when i'm very loud when i spew so i was like like everyone could hear me it was
not not good not good um green grapes are purple grapes purple because they're sweet
green is sour and stinky i don't like sour you have a tentacle for 24 hours what you're gonna do
take a collage and jerk my pintus as much as i can um find a reefling that's willing to let me have
a go so yeah that's probably what i would do um her pintus uh i've got go bed please rest well
no it's not gonna be six hours long actually i need to do the membership right and stream
in a minute okay we'll wrap it up we're gonna wrap it up is anyone is sheepster's stream in the day
or am i redirecting into someone it someone it is from my redirect into someone it hold on let me
check let me check let me check details customization redirect and
um okay alias is doing just chatting so that that that works out save okay we'll redirect into alias
uh she's streaming later she'll be streaming later no one's live right now wait the what time
does the member stream start so i'm going to go offline when i finish up these questions i've
still got a few more questions to get through i'll redirect into alias and i'll take five minutes
to get a snack some food in me actually i'm gonna get some food i'm going for a yes and i'm gonna
get a pee and then we will make the script for this week hi thanks for joining i'm answering
little questions love you strongy you you say you can't sing but i'm hoping for a karaoke
stream sometime so i can hear you sing sherry sherry lady going through the motions
where did i find you listen to your heart that one yeah that one grabs time to eat yes i will uh
you'll hear me munchin okay sorry about the jump scare and yes that cat is known as a werewolf cat
as an apology have pictures of my tarantulas uh they would be blowberry shark keeper bab and dev
what oh you named her are we tarantula can i show them on stream you didn't specify
is there any identifying i don't want to show if there's any identifying
information in these pictures i don't see any reflections that could jib bait you
those old world or new world tarantulas they all they look new world right i'm not going to show
it i don't know if it's comfortable you know please don't show them okay sorry sorry my apologies
let's not do that a modern talking i love it i love that you stream every day i always have
something to look forward to oh i'm glad you enjoy it i'm like damn you guys are probably sick of
seeing me online what historical event or period do you find the most interesting any revolution at
any point in history i'm actually doing an education stream about revolutions soon so i hope you're
ready for it um uh you unironically motivate me to improve my life after i saw you bring veal
or to life oh right now i'm trying to get in shape try hard a little bit more at my job and
try to touch graphs a bit more often genuinely thank you much love much love rief lin that's
fantastic i'm so glad that um we can be a driving force literally because like if you think about
we just giving off i'm playing my childhood games i'm flirting around doing my burping around
is probably more accurate thing but i'm so glad that you can um what's the word you can
incorporate the endurance in you that i know that's not at all what i was trying to say uh
that you are you know motivated yeah you can take some of that motivation there was the word you're
used in the damn thing okay um hi strongy oh okay hi strongy i recently bought new shoes from my
drug dealer i don't know what he laced him with but i've been tripping all day
yeah you should feel shame that was awful don't don't do that again hi mom i know you want us to
support the other girls and spend our time with them instead but i only have eyes for you oh yeah
the watermelon got you watermelon that watermelon in here well who whoa i didn't realize how much
jiggle physics i had what the heck oh my god nari what the fuck i didn't realize how
i did not realize how much they did but yeah damn nari caught me synced out the wazoo with
these bad boys strapped down well you go back to playing elden ring yes um there is going to be a
lot of endurance streams when my dad goes home um we're going to go revisit skyrim we're going to
revisit elden ring um be sure to visit yeah nari cooked for real for real
hey hello momay hello replaying this is my first marshmallow ever i've spelt it mellow
yeah but you're so nervous stronties jiggle physics like she's underwater honestly i'm kind
of nervous sending it don't be but i wanted to say that i managed to find you oh yeah you found me
right impromptu karaoke let's go i'm glad to say that even though i'm a new refland hi new
replaying it's okay you can be a refling at any stage i love you a lot and i'll stick with you
through all the endurance streams are you sure you can keep up uh i've got quite a few endurance
streams planned when my dad goes home ps i made a bibu pick but i think i'll make a better one for
you to enjoy while sending tiggy also sorry for being forward uh um i don't i don't know how to
even censor that word uh unique merchandise uh that violor might get uh in the future um once
all the girls hit 10 000 subscribers i'm going to contact a company and see if they will entertain
it the problem with trying to get uh a collaboration is they need we need to provide evidence of sales
for them to even bother with what we're gonna ask for so i'm gonna wait until we're all 10 000
subscribers i don't know if we're gonna get a shared one that might be the only way where all
our faces are on the same package um but if we do get it the girls will be releasing a free public
audio that would complement this unique merchandise we may or may not get
uh but you will be eating good either way okay a shared one for sharing well no really but yeah
they need to see a potential return yes so i think it's a bit too premature for lack of better words
to contact the company um but yes if uh don't be shy to subscribe to the other girls as well
not just me uh because everyone this is a a rising tide no a high tide rises all ships or whatever
the heck the saying is always forget it ideas for gender three a girl who is totally not your
government agent trying to get you to pay taxes don't mind the fact that she's literally glowing
honestly that's hilarious i wish i could uh skillfully sidestepped why thank you
hi strawney i love you love you too little wifling one question have you thought of playing
dang gan ron ron pa dang dangin ron pa i don't know what that is i am so sorry hold on dang
gan what is dang gan ron pa with an n uh dang gan ron pa is a japanese video game franchise
created by and the series primarily surrounds various groups of apparent high school students
who are forced into uh mercying each other by a robotic teddy bear named mono kuma what that's
great what it's good but also curves
should be a vn is it okay maybe maybe maybe i'm needing some games that are a bit more chill you
know um so i wouldn't mind well even though apparently teddy bears try to perish them all
what about persona i i will never say no to a suggestion unless i know that's not gonna work
and have i played balder's gate no i've not played big baldy's gate i want to play it with you for
the first time you guys can carry me through the game because i don't understand it to be honest i've
seen like fucking two minutes of gameplay love the vibe on the stream whoa i'm vibing you don't even
have to hypnotize me but i'm glad you did thank you sorry i don't know why i randomly just started
singing your marshmallow but i appreciate it nonetheless okay open my scalp and dump a big
steaming stinky load of knowledge into my skull mummy oh yeah you excited for the education
stream it's gonna be a prototype and if it goes well then i'll be making more education streams
and i'm gonna call it get educated get educated get educated and the thumbnail is gonna be
um
why he's saying it like that uh i really want to see you try fear and hunger even if a little
rage um your dad sells anyone i'm also this your dad you know what your dad your dad wanks on all
fours so yeah take that you how do you mummy how do you weflin i ordered a very energetic backdoor
figurine to go along with your tofu audio audio this month thank you for censoring the crap out
of this marshmallow also she be cracked something inside me when she did her unique audio on twitter
i've tried it in the past but i didn't get anything hopefully the figurine makes a difference
i'll share what it looks like once it right ooh reeflings feeling adventurous i didn't even have
to break in for that that's sorry and that was the quite the quite the comeback there
scrape it off your mum's teeth wait a moment i feel the need to respect my character skill max
points strontism to achieve your levels of productivity much love from this little reef
like anything for you um someone says i made some Celtic folklore ai ai songs i'm so sorry i
can't open it in case it isn't that and it's just someone you know that uh you know the thing
um ASMR idea cute injured cutfish gets caught in a net by a passing fisherman and repays him
with mind breakage that's just straight up my lore that's my lore hey wait a minute that's my lore
um
you mentioned about go to the girls being unable to get an alternative outfit
no there would be no outfit that's that's what the problem is
no all the girls can have alternative outfits the other thing we were discussing was no
armor on the girls and that's what we were discussing okay lovely idea info dump us show
us your smartness i'm we're approximately smart in a few things not everything but a few things
um do you have any professional opinion on twinks yes very breedable and are wordable
thank you i'll be here all day please do not clip that i'll get in trouble
uh moment do you like when tripple you oh sorry uh moment do you like
when our legs shake and convulse uh yeah you mean it's uncontrollable
yeah you didn't manually do it okay
uh stroney read this in silence
wait what wait i'm sorry i need a breathe holy crap
wait for the ASMR booth let's go love love free fun okay my mouth is by yeah my mouth is wiggly
i've not i've not set up the model nari cooked so hard i actually haven't set up this model
there's nothing that's been altered on it that's how good the rigging is
all right what do you mean you've been streaming for a month and you didn't set up your model yeah
yeah i'm in professional what you're gonna do about it
you're gonna ink yourself good show me right now
the only time she can be silent is not breathing honestly that's very true very very true
uh i'm trying to make sure nothing's too bad
uh i'd like to give you a hypnosis script once i'm finished
is that a google drive link how dare you you're going to see the email i access that
with i shrony cows how i refling oh maybe refling maybe not maybe maybe you're snippet
are you a harem identify yourself are you a snowberry or a pin pal or maybe a bleeding heart
hmm as you command the mech has secret toggles even the pilot doesn't know about
what secret toggles secret toggles secret toggles through the toggles secret secret secret um
sorry i'm getting so distracted the debut veiler and the great content you've all created has been
amazing and i excitedly look forward to seeing more from you and the girls heck yeah i just wanted
to ask what are the pink things on your shoulder and neck these are tape my dear refling i love me
so i've got like pink little tape design i've got it on my neck i've got it on my arms
i've got it around my wrists i've got it on my thighs and i also have this tape around my little
ankle well just above my ankles too but this is all my tape i got i got tape over something else
but uh i can't say that word out loud hey pretty pink tape yeah lots of tape lots of tape tape tape
um uh i love hypnosis and it's good to see more people interested got any preference or opinion
various types of content audio art uh i like audio the most veiler lover mama can easily mind
break us but i wonder what it would take to do it to her go in the back door you've won
one finger and i'm yours that's all you need to do one finger and all you hear is the like
glass shatter mind break dot mp3 file play that's it all you all you done all done nice news uh
and hey stroney just found you recently and you've quickly become my favorite oh yeah am i your
favorite are you the owner no not legally on paper or is there a board no i can't legally own the
company smile it's not my company um do you ever get gen do you ever get jealous of your gen
mates good looks i designed myself and approved by design what do you mean and what do you mean
that wasn't a reef the reefing wouldn't say that ah terrible behavior um
hold on universal basic income hold on reflin who's asking about you that universal basic income
is something we will soon see in our lifetime meaning we don't have to work for money anymore i just
want to say that you don't have to feel guilty if and when you slow it down on the whole high quality
content dump oh i am a content producer myself and know how stressful it can be so please remember
you don't owe us anything i love you and please prioritize your health a little bit more it breaks
my heart seeing you not be on your a game in terms of physical health i'm i'm doing better um as i said
i'm doing a lot shorter streams over the next few weeks because my dad's uh he's literally packing his
suitcase i spoke to him yesterday um i am going to be doing like four hour streams i'm so sorry for
how unnerving that's gonna be um but yeah no chest envy um i actually don't want my chest um i if i
get an alternative design i don't know when that's gonna be um i want i i maybe might get a wee bit
the only reason my um i have any goobies on my chest at all is because of the lore that i have
five daughters and um the way that the straps are they're actually pushing them together but they're
not actually this big so it's a bit of a a hiddenness hidden lore uh if you will um thank you strongy
uh oh no love you strongy i misread that love you strongy love you reefland thank you for everything
you've done over the year yes the year that i've just got started why yes of course you are an
inspiration and a role model i'm sure not just for me you have made me more comfortable with
my benchul feelings and learned the shame i feel and lessened the shame i feel for my existence
in my desire for love it's human nature it's human nature to beat your shme i ain't judging
you've made me more open tolerant and ready to receive you and well life has to offer you are
a force for good in this world i hope you never forget that thank you amen hey i just want to
hug you and cry happy tears oh little reefland that's so precious i wish you all the success in
the world love you forever oh reefland what would be your biggest girthiest dream i what reefland
where did you just go with that what would be your biggest girthiest dream to achieve in your
life i hope you will achieve all of your dream um i don't i've got what i've won i've got my reefland
so i don't know maybe my only comment my only comment would be it would be nice to get a play
button is me do you know what i mean just kind of as me as strawnee that would be very i think
maybe that's the only thing i want to work towards and i mean hell i think what we're about at 9 000
so i'm nine percent of the way there anyway you know the miles are bouncing up and down everywhere
yes they are wink wink get it bouncing up and down haha i just added that into your sentence
uh i think the reef wants to know if you're a size queen or not what does that mean oh god
sorry hold on uh some of the terminology is going in and out my head what is a size queen
question mark come on google pull through size queen uh someone who prefers
a large pentus
i have tight climb syndrome get that away from the fist of the back door fine okay i'll tolerate that
check the end of the snack review stream and you will have your answer oh yeah actually that's true
someone didn't get the memo it's so ogre yes i have tight climb syndrome i went to uh i got to
i got to my clam prized open to see the peril inside and they were like yeah you're you're
absolutely uh yeah yeah for the so the you need to use this device it's called a
speculum in order to speculate inside for the peril if you will and uh yeah i had to like
use the fucking tiny one i was like uh please please use the smallest one you have and she was like
yep i i know why i can see you know why and i'm like yeah thanks thanks it's terrible um
i online runnically started planning my day around your streams thank you for your hard work
woman thank you for planning your day around me i appreciate it uh like damn you really listen
to my voice every single day get down don't you get voice fatigue hearing me
i surely you get a bit of voice fatigue hearing like the same thing coming out of me
i bet you hearing mickey mouse the day was a respite
no it gets better every day get it would you ever date a refund come to the convention okay we're
gonna get kicked out on purpose i'm gonna do things that are unheard of i'm gonna have a little
sign and it's like one one cent i step on you one cent i sit on you one cent i
terrible you did different voices how could there be fatigue
ho ho what are you talking about okay this reefling says speaking of bouncing up and down
i want you to bounce up and down on me repeatedly for many hours every day ho ho
i'm so sorry to the reefling that sent that seriously and then i ended up saying it mickey
mouse thingy guess i'll stop tessie it tossing my pennies then toss the coin to your cuttlefish
even though i've never played that game i don't know how the song goes but i'm pretty sure it
goes toss the coin to your witchers mummy i'll be honest with you okay what you've been honest with
me about when i get super hmm i like to imagine you are wording are you the brave reefling that
said the our wording thing are you squinting me right now right let's do it again i was close
the mickey mouse voice thank you for the five dollars kfp spady spady mc spady that's actually
in scotland sort of spady the the mickey mouse voice really got you going
ho ho oh the way i want to bounce up and down on you reefling i'm going to lean over you from
behind i'm going to take my hand and lower it under and i will whisper in your ear what a good
little reefling you good and time to get your reward ho ho that's absolutely so cursed i don't
think i've uttered anything more disgraceful in my entire life than that what i've just said
uh i usually refrain from inking or doing to me
reefling oh i will never be able to enjoy another disney movie again great it's
inverted now oh it's going back inside oh he's shy he's shy that's like ancient
egyptian tomb raider robber cursed
this is making me discover things about myself buddy hope not a bloody hope no i don't know if
you do well i wanted to make a heavy scottish accent audio at some point like take it out like in my
heavy scott's book maybe you save it for a meme of the norm at work i had your latest
patreon audio on my mind you're far too dangerous anyway three guesses how my lunch
how your lunch break was spent love the hard work you do for yourself and your door
reefling are you doing things that are naughty and we shouldn't be doing and i shouldn't be
encouraging you right now i poor no disney no it's metal if disney uh strikes me
down okay i per thank you for the super chat encourage please no i can't encourage it because
it's dangerous you could like can you know like lose your job i don't know i don't want to get in
trouble oh my god um acapella media just tweeted out of the stream i am i need to thank you i am
gonna wrap it up there oh i am so sorry i didn't know acapella media tweeted about the stream
oh no
oh no okay thank you so so much reeflings for the stream oh no
um i had so much fun that was fantastic thank you for letting me roleplay as my gen mates we
didn't do anything after that oh my gosh i'm so sorry acapella media thank you for freaking
interviewing us though that was hilarious um i'm so sorry i'm going to go offline to end
there uh i respect for acapella media i'm so sorry please don't uh i'm sorry uh uh uh and um i am
going to take five minutes and then i'll come back and do the membership brighten stream
uh so give me five minutes i'll make a tea i'm going to get some food and go for a tinkle
winkle uh i am so sorry acapella media my apologies uh my apologies for that me sorry sorry sorry uh
um okay i i'll talk to you later alligators i'll see you in five minutes okay i'm so sorry
i'm so sorry okay bye bye bye